[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend zusammen
sollen frauen im fußball das gleiche
verdienen wie männer ein thema heute im
sport christian hat stichwort
gleichberechtigung in 15 minuten genannt
das sind die themen an diesem dienstag
coroner regeln für den herbst auf den
vorschlag des bundes folgt deutliche
kritik die länder fordern
nachbesserungen
razzia bei donald trump des fbi
durchsuchte das anwesen des ex
präsidenten in florida wohl wegen
mitgenommener dokumente aus dem weißen
haus
gleicher lohn für gleiche arbeit das
fordert der kanzler beim dfb nach ihrem
gefeierten auftritt bei der em sollen
die fußballerinnen nicht mehr schlechter
dastehen als die männer
vor wenigen stunden trafen sich bund und
länder zu einer virtuellen
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
schließlich gibt es neben krieg und
energiekrise immer noch eine pandemie
die uns in einigen monaten wieder viel
stärker herausfordern könnte für den
herbst hat die bundesregierung diesen
plan vorgelegt die maske bleibt pflicht
in fernzügen und flugzeugen außerdem
soll es eine masken und testpflicht den
krankenhäusern und pflegeeinrichtungen
geben die länder könnten die masten
pflicht noch ausweiten beispielsweise
auf den nahverkehr auf schulen oder auf
die gastronomie die länder das wurde
heute deutlich sind nicht begeistert und
beim thema impfen kochen die gemüter
richtig hoch britta spiekermann
wer darf rein und wer nicht im herbst
die länder sollen masken schlicht in
innenräumen vorschreiben können es sei
denn man es getestet frisch genießen
oder erst vor drei monaten geimpft es
besteht gesprächsbedarf über den entwurf
auf der sonderkonferenz viele lücken
heißt es gute grundlage heißt es auch
und viel enttäuschung der wunsch nach
klarheit in der vielstimmigkeit
erscheint übermächtig wir haben auch
richtung impfungen empfehlungen für alle
nach rücksprache mit dem hausarzt die
stiko ab 70 die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ab 60 was sollen die
menschen draußen zu diesem thema noch
denken es ist jetzt das dritte japan und
wir müssen insbesondere das ist auch ein
wunsch der gesundheitsminister ungesund
ermittlerinnen dass wir regelung finden
die die menschen noch verstehen
lauterbach hatte den gesetzentwurf mit
fdp-justizminister buschmann
ausgehandelt doch viele liberale sind
unzufrieden mit dem eigenen minister und
karl lauterbach er hat erneut die vierte
impfung für im prinzip alle empfohlen
schon wieder die ständige impfkommission
lehnt das ab und ist auch heute sauer so
professor von kries mitglied der stiko
der ständigen impfkommission es wäre
besser wenn lauterbach seine zunge etwas
besser im griff hätte der widerstand
wächst nicht nur bei der stiko wenn man
jetzt sagt es die impfung gilt nur für
drei monate dann signalisiert dass den
leuten sie ist schützt nicht vielleicht
nur für drei monate und das ist nicht
wahr die impfung schützt viel viel
länger sich jetzt sicherlich deutlich
länger gerade vor der schweren
erkrankung und darauf kommt es ja an und
deshalb finde ich das hier schon
problematisch dass so eine regelung
eingeführt wird der bundestag soll das
neue infektionsschutzgesetz im september
beschließen noch herrscht politischer
und wissenschaftlicher streit es
überwiegt verärgerung und prunk und
wie sich die infektionszahlen im herbst
entwickeln könnten darüber haben unsere
online kollegen mit einem corona
modellierer gesprochen das können sie
nachlesen in unserer zdf heute app
seit heute gilt der gas notfallplan der
eu zur vorbereitung auf einen möglichen
stopp russischer lieferungen er sieht in
jedem land freiwillige gas einsparungen
von 15 prozent vor der chef der
bundesnetzagentur müller warb im zdf
dafür in deutschland sogar 20 prozent
einzusparen mit den eu-weiten
einsparungen könne dies dazu beitragen
und das genug gas da sei um gut durch
herbst und winter zu kommen
zum krieg in der ukraine die usa haben
weitere militärhilfen in höhe von einer
milliarde dollar angekündigt darunter
munition und panzerabwehrraketen in der
ukraine gehen die gefechte im süden und
osten des landes unvermindert weiter
unsere reporterin anne brühl war mit
ihrem team an der kampflinie person
unterwegs
sie kämpfen mit waffen die 80 jahre alt
sind wir sind nahe der front bei die
ukrainische armee hat uns mitgenommen zu
einer ihrer stellungen
wir brauchen so viele waffen wie möglich
in aller kürzester zeit damit wir diesen
krieg schnell beenden können ich möchte
betonen dass heute die ukraine nicht nur
ihr eigenes territorium frauen und
kinder verteidigt sondern auch europa
die schützengräben haben die russen
ausgehoben die ukraine haben die
position zurück erobert die soldaten
nennen uns nur ihre kampfnamen gerade
erholen sie sich von angriffen die auch
immer wieder dörfer in der nähe treffen
sie vor vier tagen waren die russen so
verrückt das dorf mit streubomben
anzugreifen
im frontgebiet treffen wir ein ehepaar
das mitten in der kampfzone lebt
sie schießen die ganze zeit tag und
nacht mit allem was sie haben das ist
normal
jede begegnung hat die ukrainische armee
organisiert stolz zeigen die soldaten
und zerstörtes russisches kriegsgerät
das z ist gut zu sehen
an der südlichen front vermeldet die
ukraine in den letzten wochen erfolge
angeblich sind 50 dörfer die sich in
russischer hand befunden haben
zurückerobert unabhängig überprüfen
lassen sich solche nachrichten nicht
immer wieder hören wir in der ferne
artilleriefeuer
horizont raketeneinschläge der kampf um
die front im süden geht wohl in die
entscheidende phase
vor diesem krieg sind laut
un-flüchtlingshilfswerk über 10
millionen aus dem land geflohen in
deutschland haben die behörden seither
knapp eine million menschen aus der
ukraine registriert wer nicht in andere
länder weiter reiste oder wieder
zurückging blieb meist in größeren
städten wie hannover dortmund oder
berlin dort in berlin kommen immer noch
jeden tag mehrere hundert an was langsam
zu problemen bei der unterbringung führt
aus der hauptstadt lisa jan die die
container auf dem ehemaligen flughafen
tempelhof müssen wieder genutzt werden
lange standen sie leer jetzt wohnen hier
vor allem menschen aus der ukraine
natalia ist aus odessa und teilt sich
ein zimmer mit einer frau aus kiew
wir sind zwei fremde und sehr
unterschiedliche menschen dann noch der
hund wir haben keine wahl wir müssen
irgendwo wohnen aber es gibt auch mal
probleme
das containerdorf eine der unterkünfte
die berliner reaktiviert hat um wohnraum
zu schaffen für asylbewerber und
geflüchtete aus der ukraine aktuell
stehen nur noch einige hundert plätze
zur verfügung bei einem täglichen zugang
von mehreren hundert ukrainerinnen rund
700 sind es immer noch täglich nicht
alle bleiben in berlin doch in der
notunterkunft in tegel übernachten sie
oft länger als die geplanten 48 stunden
denn auch bundesweit kommen städte und
gemeinden an ihre grenzen die sorge dass
wir natürlich auch nicht mehr auf den
wohnungsmarkt zugreifen können sondern
jetzt langsam zunimmt wieder auf touren
halten und dergleichen oder
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte zurückgreifen
müssen in der container unterkunft
versuchen marina und ihre familie sich
so wohnlich wie möglich einzurichten
wir leben von tag zu tag und versuchen
es uns gemütlich zu machen aber wir
möchten gerne wieder ein eigenes zuhause
hat sie suchen bereits nach einer
wohnung wie so viele in berlin und
anderswo
dass das fbi razzien durchführt bis
völlig normal dass das fbi dies bei
einem ex präsidenten tut ist bis gestern
abend noch nie vorgekommen die agenten
durchsuchten einen luxus anwesen von
donald trump der die razzia selbst
öffentlich machte und von politischer
verfolgung sprach trump soll dokumente
aus dem weißen haus mitgenommen haben
deren inhalt die nationale sicherheit
gefährdet aus washington elmar theveßen
sie kamen um 9 uhr morgens in
zivilkleidung ein dutzend fbi-agenten
den ganzen tag durchsuchten sie mal lago
den wohnsitz des ex präsidenten in
florida er ist donald trump statement am
montagabend machte die operation
öffentlich trump nennt sie unnötig
unangemessen und co aber das fg handelt
im auftrag des justizministeriums und
auf richterliche anordnung der verdacht
trump habe streng geheime dokumente
entwendet
man muss dann einen bundesrichter von
einem begründeten verdacht überzeugen
dass eine straftat begangen wurde und
dass die beweise dafür an eben jenem ort
sind
das fbi suchte gezielt brach sogar den
safe von donald trump auch schon im
januar hatte das nationalarchiv 4 15
kartons beschlagnahmt darin auch
briefverkehr mit nordkoreas diktator kim
immer wieder soll trump unterlagen auch
ins klo gespült haben wie diese fotos
belegt
james selbst hielt sich am montag in new
york auf ließ seinen sohn eric für sich
sprechen das weiße haus will offenbar
den mann angreifen den es als größte
bedrohung für joe biden sie
das fbi werde als waffe gegen den
politischen gegner missbraucht wittern
führende republikaner und auch vor
trumps wohnsitz sammelten sich schon in
der nacht seine anhänger sie ermitteln
gegen trump weil sie angst vor seiner
kandidatur haben meint sie er wird
wieder gewinnen
sollte das fbi hier streng geheime
staatsdokumenten gefunden haben drohen
trump eine geldstrafe und bis zu drei
jahre haft
wir wechseln den kontinent jetzt ein
blick nach kenia eigentlich eines der
stabilsten afrikanischen länder bei
touristen beliebt aber auch gebeutelt
durch die lahmende weltwirtschaft dort
wird ein neuer präsident gewählt kenia
mit seiner hauptstadt nairobi liegt im
osten afrikas und steckt in einer
schuldenkrise für die bevölkerung heißt
dass höhere steuern und gleichzeitig
wird alles teurer die lage zu verbessern
das versprechen die beiden favoriten der
wahl für die sich gut 22 millionen
menschen haben registrieren lassen so
sand von lojewski
wahlen in kenia beginnen immer schon in
den frühen morgenstunden und schon vor
öffnung der wahllokale bildeten sich
lange schlangen wie auch hier in
marseille bezirk wajid ist die spannung
groß wer der neue staatspräsident das
land
die menschen in kenia werden eine
führung ihrer wahl bestimmen eine
führung von der sie wissen dass sie die
wirtschaft des landes ändern wird die
schwächelnde wirtschaft des landes ist
das beherrschende thema im wahlkampf
vizepräsident william ruto der jetzt als
staatspräsident kandidiert will vor
allem die sozial schwachen ansprechen
ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass die
menschen in kenia eine wahl treffen die
unser land in die zukunft führt
mutus hauptkonkurrent polit urgestein
raila odinga der 77 jährige hat eine
frau als vize kandidatin martha car uhr
ist eine top juristin gilt als nicht
korrupt carola gehört zur größten
volksgruppe den kikuyu und sichert damit
viele stimmen dieser platz das ist ein
vorteil sie wäre die erste frau als
vize-präsidentin sie wird es für andere
weibliche führungskräfte leichter machen
viele junge leute sind auch in kenia
politikmüde haben sich nicht für die
wahlen registrieren lassen bisher
verläuft die abstimmung weitgehend
geordnet wie friedlich die wahlen
verlaufen hängt entscheidend davon ab
wann das ergebnis vorliegt das land
leidet noch immer unter dem trauma von
2007 damals hatte sich das wahlergebnis
verzögert es kam zu massenunruhen und
über 1000 menschen starben so sind
diesmal 150 tausend sicherheitskräfte im
ganzen land unterwegs um kenias
demokratie zu schützen
der klimawandel ist deutlich zu spüren
seit mitte april hat es in deutschland
nicht mehr über einen längeren zeitraum
geregnet klimaforscher prognostizieren
dass hitze und dürreperioden bei uns zu
nehmen werden die der vergangenen monate
stellen ein immer größer werdendes
problem für mensch und natur da sie sich
das zum beispiel auf das leben von
fischen auswirkt zeigt isabel de la vega
schlechte zeiten für die forellen der
fischzucht im hessischen herzberge die
hitze und die dürre setzen den tieren zu
die fische können auch quasi knapp über
wasser halten problem haben wir mit der
hitze mit der trockenheit das hat oben
von bach hat viel zu wenig wasser kommt
das wasser erwärmt zuschauer
dementsprechend anderen verstärkung weil
die fische hier den klimawandel sonst
nicht überstehen würden muss über
belüfter permanent sauerstoff in die
forellen becken gepumpt und das wasser
insgesamt umgewälzt werden erste hilfe
brauchte es auch für diese fische an der
aller bei wolfsburg starben bereits
hunderte die wasserstände sinken lagen
sie am rhein vor einigen jahren noch
durchschnittlich bei rund drei metern
liegt der stand aktuell bei 1 47
eine messstation am main die experten
weisen darauf hin dass bei fischen der
stoffwechsel von der hitze fatalerweise
angekurbelt wird
diese hohen wassertemperaturen haben
dann eben auch zur folge dass die
stoffwechselvorgänge eben schneller
abspielen und
ja das führt im allgemeinen zu einem
höheren sauerstoffverbrauch es gibt aber
maßnahmen die gegen den sauerstoff
schwund im wasser helfen könnten wie
eine bepflanzung der ufa mit bäumen
und trinken wer tatsächlich beschattung
von fließgewässern das ist das was uns
hilft die fließgewässer runter zu kühlen
und den eintrag von schadstoffen über
die fläche wie auch über kläranlagen zu
reduzieren das umzusetzen wird wegen der
steigenden temperaturen immer
dringlicher
der georg büchner preis gilt als eine
der bedeutendsten literarischen
auszeichnungen im deutschen sprachraum
er geht in diesem jahr an die in der
türkei geborene autorin emine sevgi
özdamar
ostermarsch schreibt seit mehr als drei
jahrzehnten auch auf deutsch romane
erzählungen und theaterstücke die jury
sagt ihr verdanke die deutsche literatur
neue horizonte und einen so wörtlich
poetischen sound
um einen ganz anderen sound ging es bei
ihr olivia newton-john mit film musicals
wie grease oder ex nhl wurde sie vor
mehr als 40 jahren weltberühmt jetzt ist
die sängerin und schauspielerin mit 73
jahren gestorben
weltweit ist die trauer groß am walk of
fame legten fans blumen nieder
jahrzehntelang kämpfte bis zuletzt gegen
brustkrebs wurde zur aktivistin
unterstützte andere betroffene
unvergessen ihre rolle als sandy an der
seite von john travolta in gries
bleibt immer nur rum jetzt sind wir beim
sport der bundeskanzler der war heute
beim dfb und warb erneut für gleiche
prämienkosten ja es muss sich was tun
equal pay das ist das zauberwort dfb
präsident bernd neuendorf bekräftigte
nach dem treffen mit dem kanzler über
die angleichung der zahlungen zwischen
frauen und männern im fußball
debattieren zu wollen und erklärte dass
das prämiensystem nicht mehr zeitgemäß
ist der kanzler trifft die dfb spitze
und drängt auf eine gleichbehandlung von
frauen und männerteams scholz forderte
schon während der em gleiche bezahlung
mit dem schlagwort equal pay hatte er
fahrt in die debatte gebracht und er ist
zudem für eine angleichung der prämien
ich finde das ist etwas politisches
anders als die gehaltsverhandlungen die
erfolgreiche spieler und spielerinnen
anderswo führen deshalb macht es schon
sinn dass man dort über gleiche prämien
diskutiert auch bundestrainerin
voss-tecklenburg plädierte im aktuellen
sportstudio für eine anpassung der titel
prämien bei frauen und männer
nationalmannschaft für den titel das
gleiche auszuschütten aber dann bitte
bei den männern ein bisschen weniger bei
uns ein bisschen mehr weil ich finde es
immer noch überdimensioniert deshalb bin
ich zumindest bereit in unseren gremien
auch darüber zu diskutieren ob unsere
über jahrzehnte muss man ja sagen
gewachsenes prämiensystem noch zeitgemäß
ist seit der em sind die forderungen
grundgehälter chancengleichheit
anstoßzeiten zur primetime
mehr sichtbarkeit und akzeptanz das
treffen heute hat gezeigt der wille zu
veränderungen ist vorhanden
nächster herausforderungen für eintracht
frankfurt vier tage nach dem verpatzten
bundesliga-auftakt gegen die bayern
trifft der europa-league-gewinner morgen
abend in helsinki im uefa supercup auf
champions-league-sieger real madrid
allerdings personal personell geschwächt
weil der eintrag dreht sich heute wie in
den vergangenen tagen alles um philipp
kostet im abschlusstraining in frankfurt
am vormittag noch dabei am nachmittag
kommt das team ohne den serben in
helsinki an der 29 jährige steht nach
übereinstimmenden medienberichten vor
einem wechsel zu juventus turin es ist
einfach so dass das philipp jetzt auch
sagen wir mal den letzten vertrag
unterschreibt in seiner karriere und das
natürlich auch eine genaue für ihnen
entscheidung ist für die zukunft was
bilder machen was will er vielleicht
noch mal anderes probieren in seinen
vier jahren bei frankfurt ist kostet zu
einem der besten flügelspieler der
bundesliga gereift ohne ihn wird die
aufgabe real madrid im olympiastadion
von helsinki noch ein stück größer
und timo werner wechselt nun endgültig
von chelsea zurück nach leipzig dann
vielen dank christian es geht übrigens
weiter mit der extremen trockenheit mehr
dazu gleich im wetter von tally
gesundheitsminister lauterbach im
heute-journal interview ab 21 uhr 45 mit
marietta slomka das war die
nachrichtenlage an diesem dienstagmorgen
sehen wir uns wieder bis dahin schönen
abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kaum regen in
sicht in den nächsten tagen denn eine
umfangreiche hochdruckbrücke hat sich
ausgeweitet vom atlantik bis in den
osten europas ja und heißluft kommt von
südwesten zu uns und so steigen die
temperaturen vor allem im westen
deutschlands über die 30 grad marke ja
kaum regnen sich denn deutschlands auch
richtung frankreich die richtung spanien
ein bis zehn liter das ist natürlich
viel zu wenig richtung italien ein
bisschen mehr 10 bis 70 liter bei
kräftigen schauern und gewittern möglich
schauen wir in die nacht es bleibt
trocken bei wenigen wolken etwas nebel
richtung ostsee das bei tiefsten
temperaturen von neun grad an den alpen
und zum beispiel 10 grad in der
norddeutschen tiefebene 18 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet morgen viel
sonnenschein und wenige wolken weiterhin
trocken bei höchsten temperaturen bis 32
grad im südwesten deutschland oder am
niederrhein ein wenig kühler dann 22
grad an der see und dort auch
erträglicher die nächsten tage steigende
temperatur nach und nach am donnerstag
komplett trocken bis 33 grad freitag
einzelne gewitter im süden und samstag
im osten und dann bis 35 grad ein
schöner abend